- I'm here with Cheryl Hines,
and with us on Skype is Michelle Buteau.
Give it up for them.
I'm on with Cheryl and Michelle,
both embrace the awkward
situations of life, as do I.
We've all kind of made
careers out of it, in a way.
So it's time to test what we'd do
in a few awkward situations,
with a game called
I'm Awesome At Being Awkward.
- ♪ I'm awesome at being awkward. ♪
(Kelly and Cheryl laughs)
- Oh my god, I love my band.
Here's what we do.
When I say, "Go", our
super-random super-computer
will flip through millions
of awkward situations
and potential solutions
to those situations.
We each have to say which
solution we would choose.
Let's see what we've got.
Go computer, go.
(Computer makes noise
indicating it's working)
(Computer dings)
- Okay, so the person in the
dressing room next to you
comes into your space.
This has happened to me.
Do you A: compliment her pants,
B: cough loudly until she goes away.
B all day.
- Oh, I think I would do A,
sort of passive aggressive.
- Passive aggressively.
- Just like, "I like your pants...
Yeah, but get."
You'd be nice about it.
- Yeah. What would you do, Michelle?
- Be nice? Who has time to be nice?
Get out of here. I need my space.
You're making me feel
that I'm in the middle
seat of an airplane. Go.
- I hate that seat.
No, I would cough loudly
until they go away.
It's weird, too.
- [Cheryl] It is weird.
- It's just a weird thing to do.
Like space, give space.
Okay. Let's see the next one.
(Computer makes noise
indicating it's working)
(Computer dings)
Okay, so you clog the toilet
at a house you're touring.
Do you A: ask if the place
comes with a plunger,
so you're owning it.
B: blame it on someone else.
What would you do, Michelle?
- I'd have to blame it on
somebody else. (indistinct)
I don't know what kind of
day they had. No, I can't.
- That would be tough.
I think you would have to
blame it on somebody else.
- Oh my god, I'm the only
classless individual.
I would just be like, "Dude.
Okay, I just did
something, and it's there,
and we're going to have to figure it out.
You got a plunger?"
- That's classy in its own way.
- It's not. I should just leave.
I should do B, but I totally would do A.
Okay, next one. Let's see it.
(Computer makes noise
indicating it's working)
(Computer dings)
- Okay. A stranger mistakes...
Oh, this has happened.
A stranger mistakes
you for another person.
Do you A: roll with it, pretending
you are the other person,
or B: embarrass the
stranger by correcting them.
What would you do, Cheryl?
- I have rolled with it.
- [Kelly] I have as well.
- Yeah. I was on a plane, and
this person came up and said,
"Oh my gosh, I love you."
And I said, "That's so nice. Thank you."
They said, "I love Modern Family."
And I said, "I do too."
And they said, "Can I get my
picture with you, Julie Bowen?
And I was like, "Yes."
- I did the same.
- [Cheryl] Did you?
- Y'all look similar.
I do not look like this person.
This girl came up to me and was like,
"Oh my god, your song 'So
Small' is one of my favorites."
And I kept thinking, "I
don't have a song 'So Small.'
And then she said another song.
And I was like, "Oh, you
think I'm Carrie Underwood."
And I literally look nothing
like Carrie Underwood.
I was so embarrassed
for her that I just...
She was like, "Can you sign this?"
And I totally signed "Carrie Underwood."
I think that might be illegal.
- Just so you can get out of it.
This one lady on the airplane one time
thought I was Kim Cole.
And I didn't know how
to tell her otherwise
because she was kind of old.
So I'm like, "Maybe
this is her dying wish."
And so she just kept
asking me about TV stuff.
I was like, "Yep."
And at the end of the flight,
I just gave her an autograph.
And I was like, "Have
fun, Esther, or Ethel,"
whatever her name was.
But sometimes you got to go with it.
But I like putting people in their place,
because I am not Raven-Symoné.
- What? Do people say that?
- That's not so Raven.
(Kelly and Cheryl laugh)
- That's awesome. I love you guys so much.
That was awesome. I love the game.
Thank you for playing.